GREG SCHECHTER: I hope you guys
enjoyed watching those OK
Go videos instead of
just staring at
this for like 10 minutes.
I thought that was a little
bit more pleasant.
But anyway, so this is HTML5 at
YouTube, Stories from the
Mobile Front.
We should have changed the title
a little bit, but it's
still a lot of the same
sort of thing.
It's a little bit about
just who we are.
We sort of look a little
bit like that.
That's me, there, and I always
wear the shirt I have.
And I got my Player t-shirt
on under here as well.
Anyway.
So I'm Greg Schechter.
I'm the web warrior
at YouTube.
And I deal with all the HTML5
features at YouTube, and I
focus on the HTML5
video player.
And this is Zoltan.
I'll let him talk
about himself.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Thanks.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Zoltan.
I work on the YouTube mobile
website, m.youtube.com.
You guys are probably more
familiar with the app.
The website gets a little less
traffic, but on the flipside,
it has to work on pretty
much every device.
If it has a browser and it can
play video, we would like
YouTube to work on it.
So our team deals with a lot
of different devices every
day-- feature phones,
smartphones, and tablets.
GREG SCHECHTER: Cool.
Thanks, Zoltan.
So when I was thinking about
this talk, I thought about,
what is Google I/O about?
And here's a picture of me from
a couple years ago when I
came to my first I/O.
And it was really, for us-- like
I was an intern at the
time, and it was about
seeing cool stuff.
We were super excited to see
the newest and the coolest
things that were happening.
And I definitely think that we
did a pretty good job this
morning, and people
were cheering.
It's a pretty cool conference.
So last year, we showed
off this thing
called the Rome Project.
And if you guys don't remember,
I'll just play this
little sample video.
It was basically just this
interactive music video.
It used a lot of cool
technologies and WebGL, and
this is all interactive in the
browser, and just showed the
power of what you do.
And this was really cool, and
everybody thought it was
really neat.
And then I tried to look
at it on my phone.
And so I took this year's
awesome hardware.
This isn't a picture of the
Nexus 7, but whatever.
And this is what happens.
I get this little
error screen.
And that was really
disappointing.
And then I was like, well,
maybe Chrome doesn't have
WebGL support on
mobile devices.
So, OK, there are other
browsers that
I have on my phone.
Let me try, let me see
what happens there.
And well, it didn't give me
the error screen, but it
certainly didn't work either.
So this was disappointing.
And then I was wondering, OK,
is all this coolness, is it
ready to use?
As developers, can we
use it at YouTube?
Can you guys use it when you're
building your sites?
Because that's what we hoped for
when we talked about all
these neat things.
So this is the story
that we're going
to be talking about.
It's kind of a battle on the
different features and stuff.
And we should have plenty of
cat references throughout,
because it is a YouTube talk.
So let's talk about HTML5.
What does HTML bring
to the table?
What are the cool technologies
that we're going to talk about
here, and that other people are
talking about at the other
talks throughout the day and
throughout the conference?
So this is just a quick
list of the different
things that they have.
And at YouTube, well, obviously,
we're a video
website, so the one that we
care about the most is the
multimedia one.
But oddly enough, we actually
use quite a few of these on
the website.
And so we'll go and look into
all these things separately
about the different things that
they provide and what we
use, and how they make YouTube
kind of awesome.
But like I said, why do--
who can use this stuff?
Because clearly, the WebGL stuff
wasn't going to work on
my phone today.
And it's for you guys as
developers, it's going to
depend on your users.
Who are your audiences?
Who are you trying to target?
And just an idea--
when I was in school, my
audience looked like this.
I didn't care about
IE as much.
Not to say that they don't have
wonderful browsers today,
but at the time, I wasn't using
IE, and I wasn't going
to focus on it for
my development.
But the last company that I
worked for, we actually cared
about IE a lot.
And we cared about if a user had
JavaScript, if they didn't
have JavaScript.
And at YouTube, it's
kind of like this.
We support as many browsers as
we can, but early browsers of
IE, we don't give them
full support.
So when you think about the
stuff that we talk about,
remember who your users are, who
you want to support, and
who your target's going to be.
So then, why are we going
to use this HTML5 stuff?
Hasn't things been working
fine for a while?
Well, let's start to answer
that question.
So the first thing we're going
to look at is CSS3 styling.
And this one I don't actually
think of as as exciting as
some of the other topics.
One of the first things
that people talk
about is rounded corners.
In the early days, it used to
require us to use a lot of
images to get this
nice prettiness.
But today, we can just drop in
a little snippet of code, and
we get this roundedness on our
divs and things like that.
And the nice thing about a
feature like this is if the
browser doesn't support it,
it's just square corners.
It still works.
It still looks fine,
for the most part.
Transitions are a little bit
more interesting, a little bit
more newer.
They don't have as much support,
and so we have to
make sure that everything's
[INAUDIBLE]
with our vendor prefixes here.
But the same thing, just one
line of code and we can get a
nice, smooth transition
to make things
look a little prettier.
So what advantages do
we get from this?
Well, it's going to enhance
the user experience.
Certainly, the transitions will
make things smooth or
make it more interesting to look
at, make it more pretty.
And it's a lot less code than
having to worry about all
these different situations
where you're bringing in
images and doing these hacks.
And because of that, you're
going to get faster
performance.
You're not going to load
images anymore.
The browser's going to take
care of it for you.
And so we're not going to
waste all this extra
development time trying
to worry about it.
So that's cool.
That's awesome.
And the experience is still
great without it.
So instead thinking about why
HTML5 for us, it's really more
of a question about
when HTML5.
We know that it's going to bring
us a better experience,
and be faster and more
performant, and all these
great things, so we don't need
to think about why anymore.
It's really about when.
When do we bring it in?
So just a little idea of how
many users get some of this is
CSS3 coolness-- well, with
rounded corners, is about 85%.
The newer versions of IE do have
rounded-corner support,
IE9 and forward, but the
older ones don't.
And so at YouTube, that's
about 85% of our users.
Transitions is a little
bit less.
About 70% of the users today
will get the cool transitions.
Now let's talk about performance
and integration.
And this is a little more
interesting, because I get to
talk about uploads.
I think uploads is
pretty neat.
So this is a picture
of our upload page.
And the part that I want to
point out is up here, that
little progress bar.
Now, we do this in HTML5.
We use XHR to do this.
And it's very simple.
We can have a little snippet
of code like this, where we
can create a request, and send
a blob or a file over.
And we can listen to the
progress updates, and be able
to have this responsive user
interface, where the user
knows what's going on.
And so it's just very simple.
We get that sort of experience
instead of just having the
user have to sit there and
wait until it's done.
And so this is great.
And why?
Because there's a little bit
more than just that little
prettiness.
But it gives us a richer
user experience with
those progress updates.
We can also do multiple
file uploads.
The browser allows us to
do this really easily.
And We can do resumable
uploads.
This API has this ability to--
if upload stops, we can start
off where it left off and keep
going, whereas before, we would
have to rely on plug-ins
to have these advanced
features.
Silverlight has these
features to it.
And certainly, with POST, we
didn't get all this great
functionality.
So this is great.
We can use XHR, and we do on our
site to enhance our user
experience.
So what percentage of our
users get this new
awesomeness?
It's about 75%.
IE is trailing.
They have XHR support in the
newer versions, and they have
core support, which we
also use for uploads.
But it's not quite there yet.
So let's up the coolness now
and talk about my favorite
portion, which is multimedia.
Obviously, it's going to be
great, because this is the
part that I work on the
most, and it's all
cat videos and stuff.
So like I said, it's
all about video.
And traditionally, we talk about
things on the desktop.
And desktop's really cool.
And like I said, we
do cat videos.
But maybe you guys are going
to produce a video website
that focuses on something
else.
And Flash has worked great for
us in the past, and now we
have this new HTML5
technology.
So what did we expect to get
when we switched to HTML5?
Well, because it's open source,
that's pretty cool,
and we can have open source
browsers, players, and codecs
help move this technology
faster and in a more
interesting way.
Without the need for Flash, this
extra plug-in, the extra
integration in the system,
we expect that
it's going to be faster.
You don't have to instantiate
this plug-in, and it's going
to be more tightly bundled with
the browser, so it should
perform better.
And of course, accessibility
is a big thing.
For example, just being able
to tab around and interact
with the video player, with just
the HTML elements that
the browser's used
to interacting
with is done for you.
Whereas with Flash, you have to
make hacks if you want to
be able to tab into the Flash
player to interact with it, if
you're using a screen
reader or something.
And power consumption
is a big one.
And we'll dive deeper into that
when we talk more about
mobile stuff.
So who can use HTML5 today?
It's about 80% of our users,
which is pretty cool.
We don't serve it to 80%
of our users yet.
But this number is great,
because a year and a half ago,
this was only about 35%.
And the world kind of looked a
little bit like this a year
and a half ago.
And this was a bit of an
exaggeration, but we had all
these places where we could use
Flash, a good chunk where
we could use HTML5, and a
tiny sliver where it was
HTML5-only, and that was
an iPhone and iPod.
Now clearly, today's world is
a little bit different.
The numbers that we showed off
in the morning show that
mobile growth is huge, and we'll
talk about that a little
bit later, as well.
But this is where we started
when we were thinking, why are
we going to build this
HTML5 video player?
Because most of our users
can have Flash.
It's been working well for us.
But the interesting thing is
when we looked at our API--
who was using our API, what
kind of interesting
applications they were building,
and where they were
trying to build it,
it shifted.
And we saw that in most places
where people were building
interesting apps, it was places
that needed an HTML5
player, because Flash
wasn't supported.
And so this was really
exciting.
This made it obvious for us
that we needed to have an
HTML5 player.
But now let's talk mobile,
because I think that's more
interesting.
It's more new.
That was the past.
We made those decisions to
go in that direction.
So what do we have to
worry about now?
So the first thing is thinking
about just why?
Why is mobile important?
Well, so this is the playback
stats that we have from 2010
going into 2011.
And we can see that
unfortunately, desktop is so
huge at YouTube that mobile is
still kind of a small percent.
But the difference is, desktop
increased by about 30% between
these years, and
mobile tripled.
And I really wish we had numbers
for today, but we
haven't quite compiled all those
official numbers yet.
But this'll be a lot more--
this is about 10% of our total
playbacks now, and if we
showed you what we had for this
year when we have all
that data, I'm sure that it
will be a lot larger.
So this is exciting.
This is a growing market and a
place that we need to provide
a good video experience.
So how do we do that?
Well, so there are a
couple technologies
we can use on mobile.
Well, there's Flash.
We can do native stuff.
And we can use HTML5 video.
Now, Flash on the desktop sort
of equals Flash on the phone.
You don't have to make
too many changes.
It's going to work.
But the problem is, you don't
get Flash everywhere.
Some devices don't support it.
Certainly, iOS is a good example
of that, and Android.
Newer versions of Android
don't have Flash.
So we kind of threw that out.
So then we have native,
and native is good.
What we can do here is we can
have a simple RTSP protocol,
just have that URL
up there that'll
point to a video stream.
And then we can serve the video,
and the phone will do
the work for us.
And this is great if
we don't have HTML5
playback, HTML5 video.
Because otherwise, we'd be
able to build a richer
experience.
We also have the ability
to open up an app.
If we have an app on the phone,
we can use a native app
protocol to open that up.
And iOS does special-case a
lot of the YouTube stuff,
which is nice for us, but if
you're building your own
things, obviously you don't
have that kind of pull.
So don't worry about
that one as much.
So let's talk about
HTML5 video.
So most the time, people think
of it, sort of like, there's
Safari in some places,
and they have
Android in other places.
And that's a misconception,
because really, the world
looks like that.
We have a lot of different
browsers.
Like, I have all these
installed on my
phone that I have.
So these are full-featured
browsers.
Opera Mini is a proxy browser
so it does things in a
different way.
And really, this is still
just a sample.
There's a lot of different
browsers that we have to worry
about when we're building
video applications.
So don't think that it's just
Safari and Android.
But now, let's get serious and
talk about best practices and
how we can build those
applications.
And so I'm going to hand it
over to Zoltan for this.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Thanks, Greg.
So yeah, it's serious
business.
So let's see how this
looks in code.
So you have a
tag, and it's great.
And let's stick a source
file in there.
It's our funny_cat_video.
And in theory, yeah, that's
all there is to it.
It's a video with a file.
And so here's where
it gets serious.
So let's think about what format
the video is in, like
what devices can play it back.
So there's a whole bunch of
different codecs that you have
to consider.
Various devices support
various formats.
Let's see the breakdown.
So H264 is pretty
much supported
everywhere across the board.
It's a great bet.
All the mainstream browsers
support it.
WebM is kind of runner-up.
We also include HLS
on this chart.
It's not really a codec.
It's more of a way to slice up
your videos and stream them.
That's the way to go for live
streaming or adaptive streaming.
It's supported in iOS and newer
versions of Android.
So H264 is a really safe bet,
if you want to go to that.
It's a good idea to keep in mind
the various devices and
their OS distribution,
the breakdown.
iOS--
pretty much every device made
in the last 3 or 4 years
supports the HTML5 video.
Apple is pretty good with
getting users to upgrade to
the latest version, so
no worries there.
On Android, HTML5 video
works on 2.2 and up.
So there's a tiny minority who
still can't use it, but
otherwise, it's good to go.
And the newer versions,
like 4.0 and up, have
more advanced support.
So if you want to use multiple
types of formats, there's the
way to do it.
You can take a  tag and
have multiple source tags
inside it, and the phone's going
to go through it, and
pick one that it knows it can
play, and go at that.
GREG SCHECHTER: So one of the
cool things, I think, about
mobile is looking at power.
And so what I have here--
I just have a screenshot.
A little video capture from
one of our data centers.
It's cat-powered, which I
think is very important.
[CAT MEOWS ON VIDEO]
GREG SCHECHTER: I tried taking
one of these systems and
having one of my servers that's
at my desk run, but
somebody had a cat allergy,
so I just had to
plug it into the wall.
I wanted it to be more
of a green space,
but it wasn't working.
Anyway, enough of those cats.
They're kind of noisy
sometimes.
But anyway.
So this is--
aaah!
That's no good.
So this is a look at some work
that this guy Yossi Oren did.
And he does research in power
consumption out in Tel Aviv.
Great guy.
And so what he did is he took
a tablet that's available in
China today that
has a WebM kit.
Because most phones don't.
Most tablets don't today.
And he did some power
consumption
measurements for us.
And so you can see here that
when the phone is idle, it
doesn't use up that
much power.
That's what you would expect,
or what you would hope.
And you can see that Flash
eats up a lot of power.
But when you're using hardware
acceleration with web
animation 64, it's really,
really small.
And so this is great.
And the H264 one is
smaller than WebM.
So we really encourage you,
when you're deciding what
formats to encode things in,
think about power consumption
for your users.
So when WebM is available on
phones, you're going to get a
good experience.
And this is first-generation
stuff, and so this is only
going to improve.
But today, it's not
as many places.
You might want to choose H264
for power and other reasons.
Although one of the cool things
that happened is Yossi
just gave us some new numbers
for looking at a Chromebook.
And I did see that the WebM
numbers were better than H264,
which is pretty exciting
because WebM is a great
technology that we
use at the 'Tube.
So this is pretty neat.
Now, let's actually talk
about sticking a
video tag in the page.
So you've got your formats.
You picked it.
What does it look like?
And here I just have a
really simple page.
It's just going to have a video
tag, and there's H264
and WebM, and both
tags in there.
And I have some screenshots
down here of what the
different browsers look like
on a mobile device.
And it's not really important to
look at all the differences
too much, but what I want you
guys to notice is they don't
look like a video tag,
except for this one.
This is the only one that I feel
like I can interact with,
that I can actually start
playing a video with.
OK, well, that's fine.
That's kind of cool.
Now, maybe there's something
that we can
use to improve that.
Well, there's a poster
attribute.
So that--
we can have our custom
poster here.
And so here's an example.
But if we look, when we actually
stick this in a page,
well, sure, this one's
kind of buggy.
That's fine.
But it still doesn't look like
a video that we can interact
with, that we can
really build--
this is not a good user
experience, because I don't I
can play these videos yet.
And so I'm going to have Zoltan
talk about what we can
do, what we suggest, to improve
that experience.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Thanks, Greg.
So as you've seen, on the poster
attribute, you can
specify a little picture for
the thumbnail, and it looks
pretty much different on each
device, each browser.
In other words, they might
stretch the image to the
dimensions of the video tag
or they might scale it
proportionally the original
image size.
May or may not put a
play icon on it.
So it's very inconsistent.
So what can we do to
improve the looks?
Well, one thing that you
can do is just not use
the poster at all.
And we do that at YouTube
at the mobile web site.
Just render your own thumbnail
with image.
You can use your own play
button to put in there.
It looks great.
It looks consistent
on each platform.
And when the user clicks on it,
it can go play the video.
That's pretty much
a good solution.
We can't do anything about it.
The platforms are
too different.
So we can do it this way.
So one interesting thing to look
at is how do the videos
actually play back?
What happens when you click on
a video to start playing it?
And there's two big classes
of devices out there--
those that support playback
inline in the page.
This is what you're
most familiar with
from desktop browsers.
The video's right there
inside your website.
The iPad does this and newer
Androids can handle this.
And there's another big class,
and it's very interesting to
talk about, because there's a
lot of phones, mostly iPhone
and iOS, which doesn't
do that.
It goes fullscreen all the
time, no matter what.
It doesn't support inline
playback, unless you're in a
web view in an app.
And so far, in general, that's
not the case, so we have to
deal with it.
So let's see what we
can do about that.
Let's see the good
parts first.
So video playback does work.
The video goes fullscreen,
which is great.
We don't have to worry
about the UI.
In fact, we don't have
to worry about the
video element at all.
It can be anywhere
on the page.
It can be anywhere in the DOM.
It can be super tiny, 1x1
pixel, offscreen.
It doesn't matter.
As long as it's non-display and
none of it's visible, the
phone will play it,
no problem.
There's also a very cool
zoom animation
that the iPhone does.
From the position of the video
tag, it goes fullscreen.
So if you put it kind of in the
middle, that looks pretty
cool when you go and hit play.
Also, on WebKit browsers in
general, it has really good
interaction with the rest
of your website.
Just like you would expect on a
normal desktop browser, all
the events happen as
you would expect.
Timeupdates, uplink, pause,
fullscreen, exit fullscreen.
You can change the website in
the background while your
video is actually full screen.
So that's pretty good.
You can keep track of what's
happening during playback and
get a really good interactive
experience.
But there are some caveats that
you have to think about.
One thing is that it is native
controls only, and the OS or
the browser provides
the controls.
No way to change that.
You cannot do overlays
on the video.
So if you'd like to do captions
or something else,
unfortunately, that
doesn't work.
Yeah.
That's pretty much it.
So about controls, Greg has a
lot more interesting stuff.
GREG SCHECHTER: So right.
So once you've gotten your
video playing, the next
obvious thing is to add
some controls to it.
So the browser gives us native
controls with a simple
attribute like that.
So we can see, here is the
Chrome ones, and if you scroll
down again, I've got screenshots
of all them.
And each of them are
a little different.
And that's really all you
need to take from that.
So what I want to do
here is call out--
this is a table of the different
support we have.
And the top row here
is all green.
That's for the Play
and Pause button.
And the Seek bar.
All these controls have
these two features.
So this is something
to keep in mind.
The other ones--
some people feel
it's important.
Some browsers feel it's not.
So now, let's think about
building custom controls.
Now why might you want to build
your own custom controls?
Well, you want to preserve
your brand.
It's very important at YouTube
that everybody, when you're
watching a video, you know
it's a YouTube video.
We have a certain
look and feel.
We have that nice red Play
button that people recognize,
and it helps preserve our
brand across the site.
So that's one reason.
And granted, you could do that
with just the queue state as
well, as we talked about
earlier, with that thumbnail
ahead of time.
But also, you can unify
your experience
across all these platforms.
They all interact a little
bit differently.
They look a little
bit different.
You can make sure that when
somebody comes, and they're
watching a video of yours,
they know how to
interact with it.
They know what to expect.
So I built a little
demonstration here.
Now, these buttons are
kind of small.
Now let's imagine we might be
using our fingers, so be sure
to make them a little bigger.
And I got a nice Play
button here.
This video will play.
How lovely.
And I can seek around in
the video just fine.
Now imagine--
now, one thing I want
to show you--
it's a new feature that we're
going to be experimenting with
on YouTube, so this is
the debut of it.
It's this button here.
Let's say you're watching, and
you're like, I need more cats.
So this is the Kitty Time button
right here, and that
will give you a cat to
complement your viewing
experience.
And if I hit Play, you
can still hear the
sound behind it.
So it's sort of an immersive
cat experience.
Now you might laugh at that, you
know, why am I going to be
using cats, but I'm doing it
to demonstrate a point.
It allows you, with custom
controls, that you
can expand that set.
You can expand your feature
set by doing these things.
And so at YouTube, we have
annotations, and playlists,
and captions, and more features
that we can add by
having these custom controls.
So that's something that you
want to think about when
building a video application.
So now, what are the
Pro Tips for
building your own controls?
First thing--
users are going to be able
to expect to drag
that progress bar.
This doesn't happen with all
the interactions for the
native control.
So remember that you have to
prevent the scroll, which is
the default browser behavior
with touchstart.
Volume can actually get
set on all the phones.
Not all the browsers will
allow you to do it.
And people are used to
using the harder
buttons to control devices.
So don't waste your
time on that.
You don't need to build
a UI to do volume.
Maybe Mute.
Mute is--
we're not quite sure.
You do have the ability to do
that, but certainly not a
whole volume [? flare. ?]
And remember people's fingers
are fat, so we recommend that
you make sure that your buttons
are big enough and
spaced out enough that people
can click on them and
interact with them.
And also, because you're
probably going to be sharing
these things with your desktop
applications and your mobile
applications, you
can use SVGs.
And this way, your icons can
scale, so you don't have to be
making new images for both your
mobile version and your
desktop version.
.
Certainly, I can hover my finger
on top of my phone, but
the browser is not going
to know that.
So don't trigger content
with hover.
And the last thing
is fullscreen.
The browsing context is sort
of always in fullscreen, so
you can kind of fake
it a little bit.
But I'll let Zoltan dive a
little bit deeper and talk
about what that means and what
our options are today.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Sure.
So if you have a video, it's
a great thing to look at in
fullscreen on the phone.
It's really more immersive.
So what can we do about that?
Well, there's this HTML5
fullscreen API that's kind of
getting standardized,
or in the process.
Unfortunately, it's not really
available on any of the
mainstream mobile browsers.
I think Firefox was the
first to get support.
GREG SCHECHTER: Right.
So Firefox added support on
their stable branch, I
believe, yesterday.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yeah.
So it's just starting to get
right, and all the devices out
there right now can use this.
Unfortunately, it would be
really nice to have it,
because then you could take the
div containing your whole
player-- like the little demo
that Greg had earlier with the
cat button--
you could take all of that
fullscreen with all the
controls and overlays
and everything.
And unfortunately we can't
do that at the moment.
So what can we do?
Well, we can fake it.
Yes.
So isn't mobile already
fullscreen?
Well, the browser is.
So what we can do about it is
take the video as fullscreen
as it will go, which is the
extent of the browser minus
the browser Chrome.
So one thing you can do if--
for example, we do this in
YouTube embeds, is just open a
new tab with just the embedded
video running fullscreen.
In that case, since the
dimensions of the screen
change, it's a good idea to rely
on the device width if
you're sizing your controls and
pixels, to make sure that
things still look proportional
and big enough to click on.
Another thing you can do is
there's this API, separate
from the HTML5 fullscreen
API, called
webkitRequestFullscreen.
It's a method on
the video tag.
I'm sorry,
webkitEnterFullscreen.
It's only available on WebKit.
And what is does is it takes
the video fullscreen, just
like it would have gone if the
user clicked on the native
fullscreen button.
It goes fullscreen with native
controls, with all the usual
caveats that applied in
the previous part.
So this works great on
an iPad, for example.
There's a couple of restrictions
on when this API
can be called.
The video has to be loaded
already, and it needs a click
event to function, for various
security reasons.
And so speaking of click events,
autoplay is another
fun thing to talk about.
So yeah, we have videos, and
we would definitely like to
play them as soon as the user
gets to their website.
So unfortunately,
it doesn't work.
What you get is a video with
a Play button and it's not
autoplaying.
So why?
What's happening here?
Well the thing is, since mobile
users are usually on a
3G connection or any kind of
mobile connection, it might
not be unlimited.
It might be metered.
They have a quota or they're
paying for it.
So in the decision, there
are pro and contra or
against both sides.
But Apple was the first to
decide that they're not going
to allow autoplaying on
videos in general.
Which devices have
this restriction?
Safari and iOS.
And actually, the other
mainstream browsers are
following suit.
So Android browser is
introducing this in 4 point
something onwards, as is
Chrome on Android.
So it's another thing that we
have to deal with in mobile
development.
So what can we do about this?
Well first let's check all
the other browsers.
Firefox and Opera
do support it.
And none of the mainstream
browsers do, and if they do,
it's going away.
So it's best not to count
on being able
to autoplay a video.
So the next best thing we can
do is actually have the user
signal their intent to play by
clicking on the video, and we
can start playing there.
And the way it works is, in its
simplest form, just hook
it right up in the
event handler--
on click event, play
the video.
So in our case, the logic is a
little more complex than it
might be for your website.
So for YouTube, for example, in
embeds, it loads the embed
first, but it doesn't have the
video URL, and it has to go
and fetch all that data, get a
bunch of metadata, make some
decisions, and see if it's OK.
So when we get the video URL,
it's an Ajax response, which
is not a click handler.
So we can't play the video,
and that's too bad.
There is a trick to
get this to work.
We have a bit of code.
The function on top runs when
the user clicks, and the one
on bottom runs when the
Ajax request returns.
And so on top, I'd like you to
look at this line that says
video tag at load.
What this does is it calls load
on an empty initialized
video tag, which does absolutely
nothing visible.
What it does do is mark the
video tag as user-interacted.
So if you keep that object
around or that tag around in
the DOM, that guy
is good to go.
It can play videos later on.
And so when you have Ajax
response, just send the source
and call play, and it
is going to work.
And this is actually--
it works in iOS.
And also, the newer Android
browsers, which introduced the
restriction, also work
like this, as
does Chrome on Android.
So it's not part of the
standard, but it's a hack that
you can use.
Another thing here is calling
play in Android and the Ajax
response handler doesn't work.
So what can we do about that?
Apparently it's some kind of
issue with the browser.
What we can do is take the
play command out of the
current thread of execution with
a zero-second timeout.
And this is a good
tip in general.
If something multimedia-related
is kind of
wonky in the browser and it
doesn't work, this is a good
thing to try, try to
do it in a timeout.
Often it actually helps and
things start working again.
These are the types of browser
quirks that we have to deal
with day to day.
GREG SCHECHTER: So now let's
talk about embeds.
This stuff is not specific
to mobile, although it
does work there too.
So one of the things, like,
after you build a video
application, and your build
[INAUDIBLE], sometimes it's
important for you make sure that
your content can be on
other people's websites.
So at YouTube, this is very
important for us.
A lot of people depend on
YouTube embeds, and it really
enhances their experience.
So this is great.
So embeds are important to us.
So what can you do?
So the first thing when people
think about embedding content
is they think of a script tag.
And this, in most cases,
is usually fine.
But at YouTube, we're more
than just a video tag.
We're a whole video player.
And we can't have the user's CSS
and JavaScript interacting
with our player, possibly
changing
the styling of things.
So we need our content
to be sandboxed.
So script tag doesn't really
work well for us.
Now, we could use
an object tag.
And for our Flash player, that
worked great for many years.
We were able to load in a full
HTML page in it, and the user
can interact with it.
But the problem was, you can't
interact with it through
JavaScript.
And we have an API that a lot of
people depend on, a lot of
developers depend on.
So that wasn't really an
option for us either.
So last, we have an iFrame.
The iFrame is a great solution,
because our content
is sandboxed, and we would
have JavaScript-API
communication through something
called postMessage.
So this is great.
We were able to build that.
And so it looks something
like that.
It's pretty simple.
You just have the video ID
there for your embed.
And one thing I want
to call out here is
that line right there.
Now, we talked about fullscreen
a little bit
earlier and how there was
requestFullScreen API.
Now today, this does
absolutely nothing.
But the hope is, once those
standards are finalized, that
this will allow us to get
fullscreen access.
So why do we have it here now?
Why is that there if
it does nothing?
And that's because our embeds,
when they go out into the
wild, they're going to stay
there for a long time.
We've had our iFrame embed
as our default embedding
experience for almost two years
now, and it still has
less playbacks and impressions
than our old Flash embeds do.
Most people still use
that on the web.
So when you think about these
things, it's very important
that you plan for the
future if you can.
Realize where things
are going to go.
When you send something out to
the web, it's going to stay
there for a long time.
So plan for it.
So pro tips, if you're going
to do an iFrame for
embedding--
very simple CSS trick
right here.
Make sure that you put overflow:
hidden on your HTML.
IOS has some issues with
resizing and stuff, so this
will save you a lot of hassle,
a lot of trouble.
The next thing that we recommend
you do is on your
body tag, make sure you stretch
it out 100% width and
height and you change the
background color.
For us, we want a black
For your application, it might
make more sense for it to be a
different color.
And this way, if somebody starts
resizing that iFrame,
then you make sure that your
background stays the same and
you're not having redraw issues
where they can see
through the white on the back.
So this is just something
useful that we have.
And the last thing here is we
recommend that you get rid of
the tap highlight color.
Now for some use cases,
this is great.
But at YouTube with our Play
button, when you click on it,
there is a visual feedback
that you get.
I can see that the Loading
icon started spinning.
I know that I clicked on
that video player.
I don't need the whole thing
to be highlighted as well,
which is kind of weird and
looks kind of sloppy.
So if you have a visual feedback
when they click on
it, you don't need that
highlight there.
And with that, I'll hand
it back to Zoltan.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Thanks.
So the last part of the HTML5
features that we have is
offline and storage.
And this is most applicable
to mobile.
The two big ones that we use
at YouTube are localStorage
and Appcache.
LocalStorage is great.
You can use it to store one-off
small bits of data,
cache some small things.
We do use that a lot.
But I want to talk about this
time around is Appcache.
So it's very interesting.
So Appcache is this way to cache
the entire website for
offline access.
So YouTube is a website that
plays videos from the cloud,
so isn't it kind of worthless
to cache something offline?
Well, yes and no.
What Appcache does do is save
us the download time for the
actual code for the website.
On mobile, you pay for code
size twice, generally--
once for the download and
once for parsing and
evaluating the script.
On newer devices, it's not
really that big of an issue,
but on older iPhones, it took
seriously measurable time to
actually parse the script.
So large bits of code
were pretty bad.
So at least with Appcache, you
can save the download part,
and that's just great
for latency and for
the users in general.
So let's see how this works.
So here's a very simple
example HTML file.
What I want to call out is
the manifest up top.
Manifest is basically a text
file that lists all the
resources on the website.
So for example, here we have a
script file and a style sheet.
And so our manifest file would
look something like this.
It's just cached the script
in the style sheet.
You can also specify some files
that you always want to
load off of the network
and never cache.
In this case, this image
is always going to
come from the network.
So that's great.
You have an Appcache, and your
users are happily browsing
with their own copy
of the website.
But the next week you
push the latest and
greatest new version.
So how can you get the users
to get a new version
downloaded?
So in Appcache, the state
of the web site
is tied to the manifest.
So if the manifest changes,
the website
is considered changed.
So one thing you can do is just
stick a comment right
there at the bottom with some
kind of build ID or timestamp.
I use the date as the
example here.
And when you push a new version,
you can update that,
and the phones might
check later on and
download the new code.
How can we make them
do it sooner?
Let's assume that your website
is communicating with some
server over Ajax.
What you can do is just stick
the latest timestamp in your
Ajax response.
And then in your code, which
knows about its previous build
ID or timestamp, it can check
if it's newer and just go
ahead and initiate the
update process.
There's this update API here.
It's a little more involved,
actually.
There's a couple of function
calls, like swap out the old
version and new version.
But this is the gist of it.
That said, Appcache has
a lot of gotchas.
One thing is that the files that
you specify to be cached
cannot have any GET
parameters.
They are considered different
files if they do have GET
parameters.
Also, some implementations, like
iOS5 and upwards, they
treat the manifest file as a
very strict list of files and
refuse to load anything
else unless it's
listed in the network.
Since YouTube streams videos
from many different servers,
we actually had to put a little
wild card there to make
all the videos come from the
network, no matter what.
Otherwise, the phone just
refuses to download them.
Also, the thing with Appcache
is, it's easy to get it wrong
in a scary way.
You don't want to have your
users stuck on an old buggy
version of the code.
Like if your website crashes,
and there's no way to update
it, that's very scary.
Appcache has these copies of the
website, and each manifest
file is tied to a copy.
So you can end up with
multiple copies.
Redirects, close to loading your
web site the first time.
303s or a history API replace
state that changed the URL can
fool a phone into thinking--
or the browser, rather--
to thinking that it's opened
a different website.
So it might end up having
the wrong URL cached.
So just a couple things
to keep an eye on.
Some implementations
are buggy.
So it's best to develop
carefully.
While testing, look
at your log.
See what files are actually
getting downloaded.
Don't assume that
it just works.
Just something to keep in mind
and make sure that your
website isn't broken
for your users.
GREG SCHECHTER: So we asked the
question earlier-- is the
coolness ready?
And I really think that it is.
It is ready for you to use, and
you have to start using it
to compete with these emerging
mobile markets.
And you know, mobile's today,
but there might be other
things tomorrow.
So I want to show you one video,
just to think about
what we're thinking
about at YouTube.
What's coming next?
And so you should think
about this as well.
I need this video here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK STARTS]
[INTERPOSING VOICES - TWO
INSTANCE OF VIDEO ARE RUNNING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK ENDS]
GREG SCHECHTER: All right.
There we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK STARTS]
ANNOUNCER (NARRATING ON VIDEO):
Since our founding in
2005, we at YouTube have
continually striven to bring
you the best possible video
experience on the internet.
But that is all about
to change.
Our latest innovation gives you
a way to literally hold
YouTube in your hand.
Introducing the YouTube
Collection on DVD.
It's the complete YouTube
experience, completely offline.
Enjoying YouTube videos
has never been easier.
With the YouTube Collection,
DVDs have been conveniently
organized into a system
of nested modules.
Simply navigate through the
modules until you find the DVD
of your choice.
Each DVD menu is populated
video thumbnails.
Just like on YouTube.com, you
can select your playback
resolution.
And yes, fullscreen mode is
available if desired.
The YouTube Collection doesn't
require the internet, but you
don't lose the interactivity.
Just fill out the comment form
and place it in one of the
self-addressed stamped
envelopes.
Don't forget to throw in green
thumbs-up or a red
thumbs-down.
Your feedback will be sent
directly to the creator of
that particular video, so you
can maintain the dialogue that
you're used to.
The YouTube Collection isn't
just a sampling of YouTube.
It's all of YouTube.
Every YouTube video
uploaded, ever.
As soon as you sign up, we'll
dispatch a fleet of 175
YouTube trucks to your home.
Your nested video modules will
arrive securely shrink-wrapped
on pre-categorized pallets.
If you live on a steep grade
or in an area with low
overpasses, your DVDs will be
delivered by pack mule.
Since approximately an hour of
video is uploaded to YouTube
every second, you'll receive
a new truckload every week.
And if you sign up now, we'll
give the entire DVD library to
a friend or relative of your
choice, totally free.
Visit YouTube.com/they
outubecollection.
Order now and select from
a number of free addons,
including trending videos on
LaserDisc, royalty-free
soundtracks on vinyl, or
weatherproof exterior DVD
shelving for when your
collection gets too large for
the inside of your home.
Order the YouTube Collection
on DVD.
Simple, economical,
convenient.
A whole new way to enjoy
the videos you love.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK ENDS]
GREG SCHECHTER: I figured
I'd end with a
little bit of a joke.
But yeah.
So thank you guys, and we're
happy to take questions.
I'm sorry I didn't have any cats
in that last video, but
we can show some later
if you'd like.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Plenty of cats.
GREG SCHECHTER: Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'll just ask it.
With iOS devices, will you ever
be able to play videos
with an HTMI5 player versus just
the native player that
they play the videos on?
ZOLTAN SZEGO: So when you
say iOS devices--
there's a tube of classes.
I don't know if iPhones will
ever get inline playback
support in their browser.
GREG SCHECHTER: It's hard to
talk on Apple's product
decisions, being Google
employees.
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
Right.
GREG SCHECHTER: We
just don't know.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yeah.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wanted to hear your thoughts
on what obstacles you think
are in the way with regards to
adaptive streaming on YouTube,
and possibly, what would it take
to use that technology on
YouTube across the board?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: What are those
obstacles, do you think?
GREG SCHECHTER: So adaptive
streaming is a pretty cool,
neat feature.
HLS is a way that we can do that
today on the iOS and on
newer versions of Android.
So we can set that up really
easily, and that'll work.
So that sort of solves the
problem, although, of course,
it doesn't have support
everywhere yet.
The other thing is there are
APIs coming out in Chrome--
and they'll be available other
places, eventually, as well--
to allow us to actually
just toss in bytes
into the video tag.
And so then we can do the
adaptiveness in our code.
HLS does it for us, but we'll
have that ability to do that
in JavaScript if we want to.
Is it mediaSource.append?
Is that what it's called?
I think that's what
the API's called.
I gotta--
AUDIENCE: AppendBytes.
GREG SCHECHTER: AppendBytes.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: So would you say HLS
is the preferred method, as
opposed to using Flash, for
YouTube at this point in time?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yes.
So our mobile site uses HLS
for live streaming, right?
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yes.
GREG SCHECHTER: And so HLS, we
can do both adaptive and live
streaming with it.
And correct me if I'm wrong, but
on the mobile site today,
we just use it for
live streaming.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yeah.
At the moment it's just
for live streaming.
GREG SCHECHTER: Right.
At the moment.
But we could do adaptive
streaming.
So that's sort of the approach
that we're taking, because
that's something that we can
get out the door today.
We will be using the MediaSource
AppendBytes API
once it's been finalized and is
available in more places.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you answered
this, but what do you think is
keeping Chrome from just
adopting HLS in their desktop
applications right now?
GREG SCHECHTER: Wait--
sorry?
What--
AUDIENCE: So on Chrome
on PC and Macintosh--
or Apple desktop,
not the iOS --
they're not capable of
playing back HLS.
Is my understanding
correct right now?
GREG SCHECHTER: I would direct
that question to one of the
Chrome developers, because
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: I'm just going to yell
it out, but one of the
things you guys had in an
earlier slide [INAUDIBLE] was
semantic, Semantic Web
and things like that.
GREG SCHECHTER: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: Using a script tag or
an embed tag or [INAUDIBLE]
tag, [INAUDIBLE] get this sort
of nice semantic [INAUDIBLE].
GREG SCHECHTER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So for people who are
concerned about SEO for
clients or things like that, how
does that all play in with
trying to use [INAUDIBLE]
and things like that.
GREG SCHECHTER: So I don't
actually have a really good
answer for that.
We don't use a lot of the newer
tags for things unless
they're specifically working
with the video tag, mostly
because the extra work that we'd
have to do to get them
working in the other browsers
hasn't really shown to be
worth our time.
SEO is not a big concern of
ours, because a lot of people,
when they're searching on
YouTube-- well, we're indexed
and all that, so we don't have
to worry about those things.
So I'm sorry.
I don't--
I wish I had a better answer
for you, but it just hasn't
been a concern of ours.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
delivering a live stream to
the desktop, if you're not using
HLS, are you doing any
form of bandwidth adaption,
perhaps statically at the
beginning of the session, to
adjust the live stream's
bandwidth to the bandwidth
of the connection?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sorry, I didn't
actually-- did you hear
the whole question?
I didn't.
AUDIENCE: How are you delivering
a live stream to
the desktop?
What protocol and what
form of bandwidth
selection are you using?
GREG SCHECHTER: So right.
So today, we can do
HLS in Safari.
Certainly that's not as big
of a portion of our
users as we'd like.
AUDIENCE: In Safari
to the desktop?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, good.
Elsewhere, we have to wait.
We have to wait until those APIs
are available for us, and
they're not yet.
AUDIENCE: So to a browser
other than
Safari, what do you do?
Like to Chrome?
GREG SCHECHTER: We use Flash.
We use Flash today.
And we use Flash for
a lot of things.
I didn't really talk about it
much today, but Flash is still
the majority of our playbacks,
because they have core
features like live streaming
and adaptive--
AUDIENCE: So then you use--
do you use RKMP,
which is Flash's real--
GREG SCHECHTER: Right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They do.
OK.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yeah, the Flash
Player today does have the
adaptive qualities which--
AUDIENCE: Right.
In their protocol, they
can do all of that.
GREG SCHECHTER: So these are
things that we're waiting for
from the browsers, to give us
APIs so that we can build
these same features.
But they're not there yet.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: This-- you might just
speculate on this, but do
you think, in the future, dogs
will overtake cats on YouTube?
And to follow that up, will you
create a button for dogs?
GREG SCHECHTER: So there's
absolutely no way that's going
to happen, and I will
show you why.
Because I will pull up my
favorite cat video, and you'll
understand that the dog will
never be able to have the same
sort of effect.
Ninja cat.
Here we go.
I just couldn't imagine
a dog doing this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GREG SCHECHTER: And on top of
this, we actually sometimes
see cats actually moving into
the dog space as well.
Let's see if that's it.
So we have videos like
this, where--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[DOG BARKING ON VIDEO,
OFFSCREEN]
[DOG'S BARK GRADUALLY
TURNS INTO MEOW]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GREG SCHECHTER: So for both of
these things, I can't envision
a dog being that stealthy
or being able
meow like a cat instead.
So I really don't expect dogs
to take over like cats have.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate that.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
And I guess if you guys have
more questions, we'll be
around the conference.
We'll be outside.
I think--
I'm kind of getting thirsty.
Isn't it time for, like,
beer or something?
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Yeah, it's
almost beer time.
GREG SCHECHTER: At night?
Thank you guys for coming.
ZOLTAN SZEGO: Thanks
for coming, guys.
[APPLAUSE]